sea fx igual a menos x cuadrada más a x
más b todo eso dividido entre x cuadrada
c x más de donde a b c y d son
constantes desconocidas la pregunta es
cuál de las siguientes opciones es una
posible gráfica de ye igual a efe de x y
nos indican que en las líneas punteadas
son a síntomas verdad entonces como
siempre te invito a que hagamos una
pausa trates de resolver este problema
por tu propia cuenta porque de hecho es
muy interesante fíjense que no nos dan
todos los detalles verdad no nos dicen
por ejemplo quiénes son estos
coeficientes abs y de verdad así que
trata de resolverlo por tu propia cuenta
muy bien ahora pensemos por ahora qué es
lo que ocurre con las cintas
horizontales es decir qué es lo que
ocurre cuando x la variable x tiende a
más o menos infinito verdad es decir
vamos a pensar qué ocurre cuando x
tiende a infinito o cuando x tiende a
menos infinito entonces vamos a ver a
qué se parece la función f x
bueno pues si nos fijamos en la función
f x cuando x es muy grande ya sea con
valores positivos o con valores
negativos verdad entonces los términos
dominantes serán los de el exponente
mayor en cuyo caso en el numerador sería
menos x cuadrada y en el denominador x
cuadrada verdad entonces en realidad la
función f x se va a aparecer a menos x
cuadrada dividido entre x cuadrada
pero esto no es otra cosa más que menos
1 es decir estaríamos diciendo que f
tiende a menos uno cuando x tiende a
infinito o también cuando x tiende a
menos infinito verdad entonces con esto
vamos a analizar nuestras cuatro
opciones que nos dan para elegir digamos
una posible gráfica de igual a fx
entonces si nos vamos primero con la
opción a podemos ver que cuando x tiende
a infinito se aproxima a menos 1 verdad
lo mismo ocurre cuando x tiende a menos
infinito y podemos ver que este de aquí
es justamente menos 1 porque cada cuadro
vale dos unidades aquí por ejemplo
estaría menos dos menos cuatro menos 6
verdad entonces justo a la mitad estaría
menos 1 entonces hasta este momento la
opción a me parece razonable ahora bien
qué es lo que va a ocurrir con la opción
b aquí podemos ver que cuando x tiende a
infinito se aproxima al valor de 2
verdad lo mismo cuando x tiende a menos
infinito entonces b no es una opción
porque debería aproximarse a menos
no al valor 2 muy bien vamos a ver qué
ocurre con la opción c aquí podemos ver
que cuando x es muy grande se aproxima a
ye igual a 0 verdad lo mismo ocurre
cuando x tiende a menos infinito
entonces nuevamente esta no es una
opción viable porque debe tender al
valor de y igual a menos 1 y finalmente
con la opción de podemos ver que cuando
x crece mucho se aproxima a cero lo
mismo ocurre cuando x tiende a menos
infinito verdad si la función se
aproxima a ye igual a cero verdad y eso
no es viable para nuestra función f
porque debe tender a menos 1 entonces
nuestra opción digamos sería la opción a
y todo esto tiene sentido porque sólo
nos dieron la información necesaria para
hallar la acin total horizontal verdad
no nos dieron la información para hallar
raíces o asiento estás verticales así
que no podemos deducir lo sólo con
con saber la información de los
coeficientes de los términos cuadráticas
verdad aunque eso sí son suficientes
para conocerla la cinta está horizontal
verdad pues son los términos que van a
dominar cuando x es muy grande ya sea o
bueno cuando x tiende a infinito cuando
x tiende a menos infinito verdad y
sabemos que se acercan a la función al
valor de igual a menos 1 por eso es que
elegimos la opción